- Hi everyone, this is Jeremy
Schifeling at Khan Academy.
Happy Monday, I hope you
had a restful weekend
or at least as restful as we can get
under these circumstances.
I wanna thank you for
joining us early this week
for a great conversation with Mark Laser
who's bringing expertise, not only as
a Khan Academy Ambassador, so
someone who's used the site
really deeply in his own school,
but also as someone who's been
using it in a cyber school
environment for years now.
And so really can speak
to the new world order
that we've all found ourselves in
where we're trying to teach
across the great divide
and reach our students wherever they are.
So Mark, thank you so
much for joining us today,
and as folks have probably
gathered from previous sessions,
we're going to do a
little bit of an interview
just to get started, and then we're gonna
turn it over to the audience
for some live questions
to finish up.
But before we get there,
I would love to know more
about your background as an educator,
and specifically with Khan Academy.
- Sure, happy to share
that, and thanks Jeremy.
I just wanted to say to
everybody that's participating,
we're all in this together,
and if there's anything
we can do to help each other get through
the current situation we're
in, reach out to each other
and we'll do that.
I think Jeremy mentioned
there's about 500 people online
now so I guess we' can't
introduce ourselves now.
But yeah, thanks Jeremy I'm
glad to be part of this.
- Hey Mark, there is
one thing that we can do
real quick if you're curious.
- Sure.
- Would you rather know
what grade level folks teach
or what subjects they teach?
Or I can ask both if you're curious.
- Yeah, I think both
would be very interesting.
For sure.
- So let's do
a very quick poll here.
So hopefully you're
seeing on the screen now
the chance to choose your grade level.
And this will just help Mark
really tailor his comments
to the specific challenges
you may be facing.
So go ahead and fill out that.
If anyone is having audio issues,
you're probably not hearing this,
but there is a message in
the chat that will give you
a number to dial in.
And I will repaste that for your benefit.
Okay, so thank you everyone for filling
that out so quickly.
We'll go ahead and close that poll.
We now have 640 people
online, which is amazing.
82% of you voted within
10 seconds, awesome.
We're gonna show those results.
And so what we're seeing right now Mark,
is that it's 40% elementary, 25% middle,
26% high, and 9% other.
- Okay got it.
- So that's really a nice split,
but with a little skew towards elementary.
- Yup.
- And then we'll do the
same for the subjects,
we'll go ahead and launch that.
And again, my apologies for not including
every possibility here.
As you are discovering in
your own teaching practice,
there are definitely limitations
to what technology offers.
So we are trying to make
do as best as possible.
But yeah, let us know
what subjects you teach,
and we will use those to
tailor upcoming content.
Okay, we'll close this out in a second.
I have to say, Mark, if
ever there was a recruiting
ground for future "Jeopardy!" Contestants,
this would be it, 'cause
people are dinging
those buzzers quickly.
(Mark laughs)
You're at 78% of the
vote, and it's looking
like 46% are teaching all, not surprising
for the elementary crowd.
- Okay, right, sure.
- A huge chunk teaching
math, and certainly
that's how Khan Academy got its start.
And then a smattering
across social studies,
ELA, science, and others,
but we can speak to those
as well if time allows.
So, that being said, I'm sorry to have
cut you off before Mark, but please
tell us more about yourself.
- Oh no problem at all.
I've been teaching in a cyber environment
for about 10 years.
Prior to that I was a strategic
account manager for Corning,
so worked in the business
world for about 20 years
and then left when it was time
to start student teaching,
when I was getting my Master's
in elementary education.
So got some experience
in the business world
and some experience in the teaching world,
but I've specifically been
teaching in a cyber environment
for about the last 10 years,
so this is our sweet spot.
There's me!
(Jeremy laughs)
So yeah, if you just wanna
flip to the next slide,
I can start kind of, you
asked about why we're using
Khan Academy, and why
I'm using Khan Academy
as an educator.
About four years ago, I'd been using Khan
pretty heavily up until that point.
We had a pretty traumatic
rollout of a new curriculum
that had been designed
exclusively for our school.
It was kind of problematic,
so what we decided to do
was focus on, I was
already using Khan Academy
pretty heavily to start
with, and I decided
to put all my wood behind
one arrow, as they say,
and build my entire
curriculum, my assessments,
my homework, and everything,
around Khan Academy.
So I've used Khan a lot
over the past 10 years,
but almost exclusively Khan Academy
to teach eighth grade math
for about the last four years.
- And tell us how you
teach, we love to hear more
about what that looks like day-to-day,
even before this whole crisis started.
- Right, I wanted to share this with you
because I think you'll
find it doesn't look
that much different than
what a brick and mortar
teacher's schedule would look like.
Morning session where we have prep,
and then some targeted
learning time for students,
and then I teach three
50 minute blocks of math,
at nine o'clock, 10 o'clock, 11 o'clock,
break for lunch.
Afternoon is set aside for
meetings, planning, IEP,
that sort of thing.
I, in fact, just came to this meeting
from office hours, so I have office hours
with students where they can stop by
to ask questions about anything
that they didn't get in
class in the morning.
And then the end of the day is set aside
for planning and grading.
So it really doesn't
look that much different.
We do teach asynchronous classes, so,
excuse me, synchronous
classes, so I actually
do have a room full of students
in front of my every day.
And if you're unfamiliar with how we teach
in the cyber environment,
it actually looks
exactly like what Jeremy is sharing here.
My lesson each day is pretty
much a PowerPoint presentation.
I prepare slides every day and go through
the lesson for the day,
questions from the previous day,
data about how students are doing,
and we have interactive
tools, just like we do
in this session, where
students can communicate
and we can talk back
and forth to each other.
One of the questions I get a lot, Jeremy,
and I don't know if you want
me to jump into that now,
or I can focus on pretty much any slide
you'd like me to address here.
- Were you gonna speak
to the grading piece?
- Sure, yeah, that came
up in another session
with Mr. Vandenberg's
session, he addressed grading
and how he grades by progress.
And I've hit on this
way that I think works
pretty well for me, I use the
assignment feature heavily.
And what I'll do is
post weekly assignments,
typically about five per week,
if we have a five day week,
I'll post an assignment
that's due every day.
And I assign each one
a standard point value,
typically 10 points.
So there'll be 50 points
worth of Khan assignments
in a typical week.
Then when I say grade once, twice,
and then per student
request, once the due date
has arrived, I will grade, and you can see
the typical scores, not
typical scores, but this
is what my grading would look like.
For this student, she
would receive 10 points
on each of those, so she'd
get 50 points for the week.
I'd look at that once, I'd load that score
in the grade book for that student.
I'd typically go back and
look at it one more time,
give them a chance to
turn in any late work,
and Khan has a really
great feature, Jeremy,
if you could go to settings.
- Here we go.
- Settings, and then download CSV,
that allows you to
download all of the work
that students have done
since you created the class,
and what I can do is
use that to extract data
that was done since
the last time I graded.
So I don't have to go
through the entire grade book
and grade again, I can
just pick the students
that completed work since the last time
I looked at the grade book.
And it's turned out to be a
pretty efficient way to grade.
So I grade once where I have the bulk
of the grading that I do.
I go at it again to pick up any stragglers
that there might be, and then if students
turn in any late work,
it's on them to notify me,
and I can do updates to
the grade based on that.
The reports that are
available, and I think
you just started to hit on one,
you were going to scores, right.
So there's some really cool reports
that you can get out of the
assignment function in Khan.
You've got the actual scores themselves,
you can go in and see how students did
on particular assignments, and also,
could you pop over to, oh good.
So you can see how students,
and what Jeremy's showing
right here, could you go back to manage
so we look at the report
for a particular assignment?
When I mentioned putting
my slides together
for a particular class,
this is pretty handy,
because it shows how many
students completed the assignment,
so I know the present.
This, Jeremy, is what
I use to build slides
for the next day.
I can look at question seven,
two students missed that,
one got it correct.
I know there's not a lot of data here,
but I can look at the gray
bar and the green bar.
If I've got a big green bar
that everybody got it right,
that's not a question I
need to spend much time on.
But if I look and see,
"Hey, everybody is missing
"question number seven," I'm
going to snip that question,
put it into my slide
deck for the next day,
and review that with the students.
So by using assignments,
you can extract that data
and use that to prepare your
lesson for the next day.
- Great, so I have a
feeling there's gonna be
a lot of questions
about grading coming up.
But a lot of people are coming to us
totally brand new to Khan and wondering,
"Okay, you've go this
awesome advantage Mark,
"in the sense that you've
been doing this for years now.
"If you were just starting
this week for the first time,
"what kind of recommendations do you have
"for someone in that position?"
- Okay, first off,
there's a ton of resources
within Khan Academy where
there's new teacher guides,
and that question is asked all the time.
So there's some pretty good resources
that Khan has available,
and I think, yeah,
so Jeremy's steering
you to that right now.
But I guess I couldn't really give
a blanket answer to that, what I would say
is assess your needs.
Are you interested in
using Khan for assessment?
Or are you using it for your curriculum?
Is it enrichment?
Is it practice?
Is it remediation?
I guess most of us aren't
doing standardized tests
this year, so there's probably
not as much test prep.
But I think, thinking about how you plan
to use Khan, the answer will vary
based on what teachers are planning to do
and what needs Khan can fill.
I will say that Khan can meet the needs
of all of these things here.
So I think that I've used it successfully
for all of those things.
So if your need is in any of those areas,
Khan could work for you.
- That's great.
And then just take sort of
the most simple use case,
where maybe a teacher
has not been in touch
with their students for
a couple of weeks now
because of lack of
technology, or equity issues,
and they've only now just
gotten the green light,
like you've shown on the screen here,
to actually move forward.
If they just wanted to get
started, just get a class
set up, just get maybe an
assignment or two out there,
how would you even begin that process?
- It's so easy.
Could you just walk us through
setting up a new class?
It really is pretty simple.
What we're seeing here on Jeremy's screen
is that he's got these
classes created already.
In the upper right hand
corner it says add new class.
So we'd click on that,
and give the class a name,
just call it demo class, or
whatever we wanna call it.
Yup.
Click next.
And then this will give you
some courses to choose form.
I want to teach kindergarten math today,
so let's choose, that's what I wanna set.
So we just choose that class, click next.
- And just to be clear,
you can actually choose
multiple of these, and Tim Vandenberg,
the other ambassador
you were talking about,
actually takes his sixth graders
and has them work
grade-by-grade to fill in
any gaps they have in
their learning foundations.
So it could be a way to
cover those kind of gaps,
using this time.
- Yeah, and actually I'm
glad you mentioned that.
Our school is now using Eureka
Math for our curriculum,
and it's super that Khan is
aligned with Eureka Math.
So for my Eureka Math curriculum,
I can use Khan's content
that is designed for
Eureka Math every day.
And then this area, where we
add students to our class,
and create the class, and there's a number
of different ways to do that.
What I do, Jeremy, is have students join
with a class link.
So with eighth grade
students, I'm generally
fairly successful with getting students
to create accounts on their own,
after a week or so I really
don't have any stragglers.
If there are students that kind of lag,
I bring them into a one-on-one meeting
and help them through the process
and get that set up.
But it's really, getting it set up
is pretty straightforward,
and there's a number
of different options that
work for teachers to do that.
- So you could just copy and
paste that into an email,
or an LMS, or a reminder
ClassDojo-style tool,
and send that off.
- Right, so that link
will put the students
into the class, and then what I can do
as an instructor, if I have assignments
created for the kids, then
I can refresh my class list,
and that automatically
gives our active assignments
to the new students that
have joined the class.
- And so just to fast forward,
just one final step here,
if you just wanna get
that first assignment out,
how would you even sort
of take that first step?
- Let's see, so if we want to,
we're just starting the year,
we're starting algebra one,
and I want the students to,
I want them to watch that
video about origins of algebra,
so I would click origins of algebra video.
I don't think algebra's that beautiful,
so I wouldn't assign
the beauty of algebra.
Just kind of scroll down through,
and in the assignments,
you can assign videos,
like we've done there.
Can we scroll down a little bit here?
If you guys look over
on the left hand side,
you'll see a triangle, that indicates
that it's a video that's being assigned.
The little thing that
looks like a piece of paper
is an article about the topic,
and then the pencil indicates
a practice exercise.
So you know what, I want
to assign the video,
the article, and the practice
exercise for that one.
So we assign all three of those.
If you look at the top,
you'll see how many things
are being assigned.
There's three assignments
that we're creating.
We click that.
And then we can choose the
due date for the assignment.
You can see that right there, what class
I'm assigning it to, if
you have multiple classes,
when you want it turned in, which students
you want that assigned to,
what time of day it is due,
and the top is kind of interesting,
because you have the ability to choose
whether it's randomized questions,
so questions are pulled
from the bank of questions
and each student gets different questions,
or you can choose that all the students
are working on the exact same questions
so that when they start asking.
I typically do randomized
for easier assignments,
and then will do the same
question for all students
when it's a more difficult assignment.
- Great, okay, so that's definitely
the sort of one, two, three steps
of getting a new class started,
enrolling your students,
making the first assignment.
Now let's come back to that next thing
you were gonna speak about,
which are other ideas
for extending your teacher's pedagogy
into this new digital world.
- Right, and maybe, let's
see do I wanna do this slide?
Do you wanna do more specifics,
or general here Jeremy?
The last slide of the day is kind of,
no, let's do this, this is fine.
What I would say, and this is something
that I've learned from cyber teaching is
that the snipping tool that most students
have available as part of
the Windows tool suite,
is so important.
I use that a lot, and
train the kids early on
in the school year how to snip a question.
So they're looking at something
in their Khan assignment,
they can snip the
assignment, and then post
it on my screen so that I can see exactly
what they're looking at.
So students aren't trying to type in,
or write on the board,
what their question is,
because a lot of times they'll do that,
they forget a negative sign,
then they enter the answer,
and it's Mr. Laser, this answer's wrong.
Well, if you use the snipping tool,
you can see exactly what
the students are looking at,
and we use that day-in and
day-out in my classroom.
And what Jeremy is showing there
is just the Microsoft directions
for how to use the snipping tool,
to snip and post on a page.
That's what I use for static content,
and here at my desk,
again, since I just got out
of office hours, I have my
Bamboo pen, digital pen,
it's kind of like what Sal
uses when he does his lessons.
Again, this is something
that is just invaluable.
It allows me to write on the board,
work through problems with students
so that I can share, I can
actually write on the screen,
and it's a lot less cumbersome than trying
to write with a mouse or
trying to do things in chat.
- Yeah, I've noticed Sal
using his Wacom tablet,
and his Wacom stylus, and he's
just super fast with that,
and I think you're the same way Mark.
So definitely a cool--
- It really comes in handy.
I'd be lost without it.
I use it every day.
And when I say static, I mean if it's just
a fixed question, if it's
just one plus one equals,
and I wanna snip that question
and then write, I do that.
I use screen sharing
or application sharing
for dynamic content.
Some of Khan's content
involves rotating things,
or moving things, or doing translations,
transformations, that sort of thing.
And when the content moves,
when you wanna move it around,
that's more difficult to
do with a snipping tool.
What I'll have students do is share,
and then I can kind of
walk students through
or answer questions looking at it live.
I think there was some
questions about that,
like how often students
are doing screen sharing
or sharing their screen versus how often
I use the whiteboard.
Probably 80 to 90% of the
class is the whiteboard
and the snipping tool, and
then when we get into lessons
where the Khan content is dynamic,
then we'll use the screen sharing.
- And just to be clear,
are students sharing
their own screens?
Or you're primarily the
sharer of your screen?
- I share my slide deck, so
what we're doing right here,
so we'll share that.
Students, in my class, don't
often share their screen.
They'll take a snip and share something
that they're looking at,
or if I want them to share,
if we're trying to troubleshoot something,
they'll share it, but more often than not,
it's just static and we're
using the snipping tool.
- Cool, that's great.
And obviously a lot of
folks have been trained up
right now on Zoom, and Google Hangouts,
and all these different tools,
and they all have screen sharing built in.
- Yup.
The rule of 24 is just something that one
of our math teachers, now administrators,
taught me about preparing
presentations for a class,
and that's just, use a minimum font of 24,
and that obviously may vary.
But just the idea is to
keep your slide deck screen
clean and presentable, and not have a lot
of small print on them.
Just something to make
it easier for users.
Checking for understanding,
one of the things
that is a disadvantage
in the cyber environment
is we don't have cameras on the students,
for privacy reasons, we're not doing
what you and I are doing right now Jeremy,
where we can look and see each other.
I can't see the student,
so it's more difficult
to check for understanding,
because I can't look out
at a classroom of faces and
see, oh they're getting this,
or man, they are totally confused.
So very important to
check for understanding
using any kind of tools
that you have available
within your software
platform for presenting,
or something like Google Documents,
I use pretty heavily for
exit ticket questions,
to check for understanding
at the end of a lesson
to make sure that students
understand the concept
and the content that's being presented.
- Would you make a
Google Form or something?
- Exactly.
I typically use Google Quizzes,
I just make a real simple quiz
that asks them their name, and
it can be anything you want.
It could be, did you
understand today's lesson?
Or you could take a question from Khan,
snip it and put it in there,
something from another
learning resource, something
from a state assessment.
I typically don't so
super difficult questions
for the exit ticket question,
because we're not there to discuss it.
Sometimes we'll do a
challenge or a bonus question
as part of that, but
checking for understanding
is pretty important, and
even more so, I think,
in a cyber environment
than brick and mortar,
just because it's more difficult
to do an in cyber environment.
- Great.
- Personalizing, just
making sure that you kind of
fit the needs of the class, and that's why
I'm typically updating my slides
right up until the
moment that class starts
with the latest data on
how students are doing,
and any problems that they
might be struggling with.
I really try to keep my
lesson presentation simple.
I don't use a lot of video.
I don't do a lot of, even
screen sharing like we're doing
can tend to bog things down, and students
that don't have good,
robust internet connection,
it will start to glitch out.
So I really try to keep
things with pretty much
a pretty straightforward slide deck
for the presentation of the lesson.
And keep things light.
Once students start to
understand your sense of humor
and you understand theirs, you can make
it kind of a fun environment.
- Great, and I know that we're running
a little short on time,
would you be okay Mark
if I took some questions
from the audience?
I know, I know, our time goes fast here.
- Why don't we just, if
we can just kind of zoom
through the deck and see,
is there anything else
that we absolutely,
positively haven't shared
from the deck?
Oh, this is something
that's really important,
and we kinda talked about
this, Jeremy, a little bit.
One of the things, that
for teachers that are new
to Khan or just joined, one of the things
I really, really like about Khan
is that I never hear Khan is down,
like, "Oh we can't do what we wanted to
"because kids can't access
the website, or Khan is down."
That just, in the years and years
that I've been using it,
that is just so infrequent.
That's not something you
really need to even plan for.
And also, and this is really nice,
I rarely have a situation where students
say the answer is wrong.
No wait, I shouldn't say that.
I rarely have situations
where students say
"This answer's wrong," and
they're right about that.
A lot of times they'll
say, "Khan doesn't have
"the right answer here."
And when you dig in,
you find out it's right.
So you can present this material
with a high degree of confidence in that.
I would anticipate,
Jeremy, lots of questions
about how to set up the class
roster, about navigation.
We've had some difficulty in matching
the Eureka curriculum with
the exact Khan lessons
that we wanna teach, just
some things like that
where you need to work to
massage the curriculum,
figuring out exactly what
your routine is gonna be,
and there's some data
that I'd like to be able
to export from Khan
that we can't currently.
But those are kind of the main challenges
when I surveyed my teaching
colleagues at Agora,
those are some of the
things that they mentioned.
- Cool.
- Yeah, I don't think there's anything
super important here
that we need to share.
If you wanna jump into the questions,
these were more general things.
- I will point out this, first of all,
'cause I think this is so important.
I actually have stats from inside Khan
that says something like only
10 or 20% of new teachers
to Khan ever play with
the content themselves
before starting to assign it.
And I think that's actually
a huge missed opportunity
that's on our shoulders at Khan
for not making it easy.
But one of the first things
you should absolutely do
is just put yourself in
your students' shoes.
See what the content looks like,
what it feels like, how
the hint system works,
and that way when you give it out,
you have that confidence
that Mark was talking about,
'cause you've been there
and you've developed
that empathy for the student experience.
- Yeah, that brings up
something real interesting
that I didn't touch on before.
When you create your class roster,
I always add myself to
whatever class I create
so that when I do assignments,
I see exactly the assignments
that are going to students.
And the third bullet
there, do every assignment
that you give to your students,
just make sure that you know
what the questions look like,
how Khan goes about solving them,
and again, it's kind of that empathy
that Jeremy mentioned so you understand
what students are going through.
And Jeremy, just as an aside on that,
after Mr. Vandenberg's presentation,
and going back to sixth
grade, I've been working
with my students on third grade content.
And I had never looked at
Khan's third grade content,
but there's some really
good stuff in there
that I'd never even seen before.
But it's some really good stuff.
- I love that.
Okay, so on that note, let's
take some of these questions,
'cause these are really
great questions for you.
So I'm gonna start with
an awesome one from Haman.
Haman says, "How do you help students
"track their own progress when
we're so distant from them,
"or so disconnected from
them, but yet we wanna
"empower them to direct their
own learning at this moment?"
So how do you get them
evaluating how they're doing?
- Sure, is this a student or a teacher?
Do you have a student loaded?
- Yeah, so we can definitely come
into the learner mode here.
- Yeah lets go--
- Go to the learner home.
- Okay, so if I'm Meaghan Pattani,
and I wanna know how I'm doing,
one thing that's really important you guys
as you're getting to know Khan,
sometimes students will say,
"My data's not recording,
"I answered this."
Make sure that in the
upper right hand corner,
you see the student's name.
Make sure that they're logged into Khan.
Sometimes students will
accidentally log out,
and they're working away,
and they don't realize
that they're not logged in.
But let's say that we wanna find out
how Meaghan is doing, and this is Meaghan,
Meaghan wants to see how
she's doing in algebra one.
We can look right there at algebra one,
you can click on that.
You see that she's mastered
16% of the course so far,
course wraps up on May 15th.
We can open that and we can see,
Meaghan did extremely well
on algebra foundations,
earning 700 out of 700 mastery points.
So kind of those assignments
that we looked at earlier
with the origin and history of algebra,
and that sort of thing.
She's done a little bit of
work on solving equations
and inequalities, let's click on that
and see what's going on
in that particular module.
So this shows, as Jeremy
scrolls down through this,
you can see she's done
very well in equations
with variables on both sides.
Now as we get into linear
equations with parentheses,
it looks like that's where she's stopped.
We don't have any work for
equations with parentheses,
and decimals, and fractions.
So Meaghan could go in and
see, "Okay, I've mastered
"this first module, and
now it's time to go onto
"the second module."
And Khan is pretty good about prompting,
once you teach students
how to do the navigation,
they'll be able to figure out where to go,
where the next step in their
learning progression is.
- Great, and so really,
if you teach students,
to review these summaries
on the left hand side,
they can start to think of this as,
"Hey, I wanna have all
these bars filled up.
"I wanna master every
single course skill here."
And it's almost a challenge to them
for the reest of the
year, can they make it
to that point of mastery?
'Cause that can be a big point of pride.
- Yeah, you wanna see a
lot of purple over there.
- That's right.
Here's another technology question,
and I don't know if
it's one that you faced,
'cause maybe your
students all have laptops,
but any recommendations
for teachers out there
who know their students
don't have computers at home,
but may have access to a mobile phone,
their parent's smartphone?
Do you feel like the Khan Academy app
is a worthwhile thing to look at?
This comin' from Daisy.
- I can't really comment on that,
I haven't worked with
students specifically on,
I know that students do access it,
our students all have laptops,
and I know when students
have a dentist appointment
or something like that, they'll say,
"Hey Mr. Laser, I'm doing
this on my mom's phone,"
or something like that,
but I don't really have,
I don't think, enough track
record with mobile apps.
I know it's available,
but most of our students
don't access it that way.
- Okay, makes sense.
And I'll just say for the benefit of Daisy
and everyone else out
there, this can often
be a lifeline to you.
If there's only one single
device in the house,
and it's a smartphone.
While you can't use
teacher tools on the app,
so everything that Mark
has just talked through
is limited to the online website,
students get a complete view
of everything on the course,
right there on their phone.
So it is a way to sort of make sure
that there's more access,
a little more equity.
Okay, great question.
- And one thing about that,
Khan tends to be really
thin bandwidth-wise,
it runs pretty well on
a variety of devices.
I rarely have any problems with students
who have extreme problems with the speed
that Khan's loading or anything like that.
- Cool.
A lot of technology questions
coming your way Mark,
'cause I think you've definitely shown
your credibility here.
Kakai wants to know, "Do
you have any recommendations
"for best practices with
integrating with LMSs?"
Be it Schoolology, Google
Classroom, whatever.
(Mark sighs)
No, I don't unfortunately.
My Khan grade book doesn't speak
to my grade book currently,
so I have to export from Khan,
and then reimport that into my grade book.
The curriculum that I do, I've
built pretty much in Khan,
so it doesn't need to
link with anything else.
I've pretty much turned
off our school curriculum,
and then I use a Khan curriculum
that I've built based on Eureka for that.
So I don't really, I'm trying to think,
I don't really do much integration,
any digital integration, between
Khan and the other systems
that our school uses.
- Makes sense, and all I was gonna add
was that obviously while there's not
a very formal integration,
I have seen teachers
come right up and after
making an assignment,
they will actually choose
a specific piece of work,
because the nice thing is
that everything on Khan
has its own individual URL,
and they'll copy this URL
and they'll paste it into their LMS,
or paste it into Google Classroom.
And that way, not only does
the student have the assignment
in their email, or on their app,
but they also have it in that LMS,
that central source of truth.
- Okay, so you've just prompted
me for something there.
That's exactly what I do.
I've got a big spreadsheet
that has the date,
the topic, the Khan help
resource for the day,
and then the Khan assessment
and that's all loaded
into our school system.
It doesn't happen automatically,
but like Jeremy said, the URLs are there
so that students can access that.
- Great, and then I wanna finish
up with two final questions
if you don't mind Mark.
My apologies for going a little bit over.
- I'm furious, furious I tell you.
(Jeremy laughs)
- Number one is, for the
folks who didn't have a chance
to answer their questions today,
what resources would you recommend
to continue the learning around Khan,
or continue the learning
around remote learning
as they go into the next few weeks?
- I would direct every question to Jeremy,
that's jeremy@khan, and
I think Jeremy's gonna be
sharing his home phone
number with us also.
So call him any hour of the day
or night, 24/7, Jeremy's there.
No, I would reach out to the
Khan user groups on Facebook,
super helpful group of people there,
and then the online help in
Khan, within the Khan website,
the Zendesk help, there's so
much good information there,
and the same questions
get asked so many times
that there's some really
good printable resources
on how to get started as a teacher,
how to get started as a student,
if you're a parent trying
to figure this out,
how to get started as a parent.
There's some really good guides there
that does serve as a
really good starting point.
And again, we've all been
where everybody is right now,
we've all been just trying to use it,
trying to get started, and trying to get
things figured out, and there's
a ton of resources there
that are quite helpful.
- Very cool, and then
last question is just,
if you were in the shoes
of many of the educators
in this country right now,
who are trying to figure out,
"What am I gonna do next?
"How am I gonna get through
the next several weeks
"or even months?"
Any words of wisdom
that you can offer folks
as we begin this week?
- It's gonna make a great
story someday, right?
Once we get through this,
we'll certainly remember 2020.
No, just I think I
might've put that in one
of the last slides, that
we're all in this together,
the goal here is to help our kids,
and help keep moving them
forward using whatever tools
we have at our disposal to do that.
You know, I thought
that, I'm always looking
for different ways to use
Khan and to improve it,
and Mr. Vandenberg's discussions,
just within the last two weeks
have been super eye opening,
given me some things that I wanna try.
So you are not alone.
We're all in this together,
and we're all here
to help each other out.
So boy, good luck to everybody,
we're all in this together.
- Awesome, well I think that's definitely
the right theme to start
this tough week on,
and I wanna thank you Mark for really
embodying that advice by taking time
out of your own teaching schedule today
to share your expertise with others.
I hope that you will take
advantage of all the resources
that Mark has shared,
we'll share this deck
and we'll share all the slides
with you right afterwards.
We wish you all a good
week and a good start
to the rest of the month.
Thank you all so much.